definitely wanted to talk to this man
because i got the steelers on on the
brain um they're going to be a
fascinating team over the next several
weeks certainly in the final throws of
the kevin colbert administration of
shopping for the groceries for mike
tomlin and the rooney family and from
the man who's been covering this team
forever and a day now from the athletic
uh covering the pittsburgh steelers ed
bouchette back on the program how you
doing ed
i'm great rich thanks for having me you
got it thanks for taking the call
so what what do you make of kevin
colbert talking up um mason rudolph's
five four and one record and how that's
as a backup and looking forward to
seeing what's next for him what did you
make of that ed
not a whole lot rich i mean he's the
only quarterback they have under
contract right now and
in kevin's words
if we started the season right now he'd
be our quarterback well he'd be their
only quarterback
that doesn't mean he won't be um you
know they have dwayne haskins they're
going to
tender as a restricted free agent and
then they'll have a couple others where
those others come from is the big
question you know whether it's going to
be a veteran and free agency
maybe some kind of small trade for a
veteran
and or a draft pick
those are the looming questions what
about the um idea of the big swing the
big big swing
in case rogers does one out of green bay
in case
there is some smoke in seattle who knows
about kyler murray's instagram page i
mean what about the big swing
going out the door for kevin colbert
what about that one
no um i'm pretty emphatic on that i mean
it doesn't mean it won't happen but i
don't i don't see it
they have more
needs than uh than that rich
aaron rodgers coming in here
is not going to make them a super bowl
contender and that's what they always
want to be
they're not going to be one either way
this year they have too many other
things they don't have an offensive line
not a very good one right now
their defense there's a lot of questions
involved there they have some
really good top-notch guys but not
enough of them
and uh even at wide receiver they're not
not very good so
a lot of holes and uh filling it with a
great quarterback an aging quarterback
and i hate he's aging with aaron but
that's what he is
um it's not going to help them what what
about deshaun watson what do you think
the the possibility
there might be
they're not going to touch him rich
they wouldn't touch him if he was a free
agent and came free
even if he has settled everything
well settling it and whether it was true
or not or two different things right
i i just don't see that happening i mean
it's not it
we shouldn't even be talking about it
because there's no chance
that's that's how much of a no chance it
would be
so what did you then make of tomlin
talking about at some point i forget
when it what it was i think it might
have been his
uh press conference heading out of the
season
uh after the loss in kansas city about
uh
mobility at quarterback and the value of
that
um yeah what about that different kinds
of mobility switch
there's lamar jackson mobility and there
is ben roethlisberger mobility you
wouldn't call banner running quarterback
but he certainly could move around in
his prime
uh take off once in a while when
necessary but
he was more
able to elude pass rushers and i think
that's more what mike tomlin meant
is something along those lines rather
than
you know uh just getting this
quarterback who's going to run for 800
yards for you every year
ed boucher the athletic pittsburgh here
on the rich eisen show what about the
draft what are you hearing about a
quarterback in the draft the kid from
liberty uh appears every now and then on
a mock draft for the steelers to take do
you think that's entirely possible ed
bouchette
i would say anything's possible but i
don't see them drafting that guy in the
first round
i think if kenny pickett were available
to them they drafted number 20. that
might be a case but
other than that i don't see them going
in the first round for a quarterback and
i i think they'll
either muddle along this year with uh
with mason rudolph and or haskins and or
someone else as a veteran
and then getting on the quarterback next
year or uh
you know just um
i don't think i don't think they're
going to get kenny pickett
i think they would want so there's no
sense at all of trying to make a big
splash a flashy play at quarterback i
know that that is against type if you
will but
you know after having roethlisberger for
as long as they had him
and just going and and because this
division
ed i don't need to remind you but uh you
know i'll just throw it out i mean
there's lamar twice a year and borrow
you see what burrow has turned into
i mean and and depending on how baker
shakes out in his fifth year
in cleveland the steelers could easily
be
dead last on the quarterback race within
this division in 2022
and and i don't know how that would sit
with steeler fans you obviously would
know better so i'll just throw that out
at you without a question
but
one like i said
aaron rodgers isn't going to change
things i mean they may have
a great quarterback but it's not going
to change
their standing in the division i don't
think
plus what do you have to give up to get
them he's not a free agent
you know and they they do have a lot of
salary more salary cap room than they're
used to
but they need to use that in our
offensive line or defensive line they're
inside linebackers they're secondary
they're wide receivers
it's just too much i just don't see it
rich
ed bouchette the athletic pittsburgh
here on the rich eisen show um what's um
you know brian flores was on um
real sports last night and
basically said he called up tomlin for
advice and wound up getting a job offer
within 24 hours um
so where do you think uh that came from
ed right where it came from i mean he
probably did ask him uh
well i assume he did ask him for you
know that kind of help and
assistance and
you know um
and mike said hey
you know
we need a linebacker's coach and
how about coming here and they they did
a deal and you know he's got the title
of a senior assistant defensive
coach whatever that means also
but
it's a good landing spot i think for him
i think
other than maybe getting a head coaching
job it didn't seem that was going to
happen or maybe a defensive
coordinator's job somewhere i didn't see
any offers there so
it's a good spot for him they have a
good uh you know carol austin is their
coordinator he's certainly experienced
and has been a coordinator in a league
and head coaching candidate and
it's a good it's a good place i mean
he can polish up some things and try
again maybe next year to get a head
coaching job and then obviously you know
uh with um art rooney wanting to um
continue the legacy of his dad with the
rooney rule
um bringing on brian flores amidst
this lawsuit
and being the owner to show that he will
not be blackballed entirely out of the
league because of it
how much of that played into uh green
lighting whatever tomlin had in his mind
for flores rich
knowing art and knowing them i would
think nothing i mean
i think it it happened the way mike said
it happened that the
and i i don't know that anybody went
beyond that and and into those kinds of
thoughts and i know those
those are things everybody's thinking
about you know
hey the steelers
bravo for them but
i think they could saw an opportunity to
get a good coach
and um it
it's been well accepted here
well what about i mean
i mean
this can't just be viewed in a vacuum
though ed i mean my gosh this is another
a a coach being brought on who's
accusing another member of the nfl of
all forms of violations of sportsmanship
gamesmanship um and now uh an nda being
asked to be signed on top of it
you know one member
hiring that coach would definitely know
that he's putting himself into at the
very least an awkward position at the
next owners meeting right like that that
never got crossed the mind you don't
think ed rich i i think martin rooney is
secure enough
in
you know in his own way that he didn't
have to care about any of that stuff
really i know his dad wouldn't have
um
and art's
you know art's in his 60s and has been
the
team president for enough
time here and
i i just don't i really don't think he
thought twice that and it happened
rather quickly so i i
don't think there was a lot of thought
you know how is this going to affect us
politically and this that and the other
thing i just think they said he's a good
coach let's go
so what is the game plan do you think
here uh for the next couple of years
based on what you've been telling me at
is that they're not going to take a big
swing at quarterback because
either it's not in their um
in their
dna or it doesn't make sense with the
rosters it currently stands to go ahead
and do something like that
and um so are they rebuilding is this a
rebuilding football team in your
estimation right now they don't like
that word no i know but but ed i got to
be honest with you for a fan base that
hears mason rudolph might be their guy
after all everything said and done and
the bengals just made the super bowl and
a big swing isn't either in the offing
because there are no draft choices for
it or the roster isn't ready for it and
other teams are going to be really
aggressive like washington like maybe
tampa and and the steelers would not be
on that front especially since let me
just finish my windup um you know the
ravens uh long-standing general manager
and ozzie newsome left them the gift of
lamar jackson going out the door uh what
else would you call it other than
rebuilding
you know except dodgy came back he's
still there um
you know i
again rich
i don't see them taking the big swing i
could see them taking a check swing okay
if you will
you know who's that like jimmy g double
like jimmy g like that's it that's the
check swing would that be no i'm talking
mint shoe
[Music]
some of those free agent guys who are
around um
something like that to bring in not to
anoint as their starter but to compete
right i can i can very much see that um
but they're not going to go for aaron
rodgers or russell wilson i just don't
see it i mean
i keep telling people to i just saw the
odds the other day steelers are third in
line odds to get aaron rodgers 550 to
you know 550 which means you'd have to
bet 100 to win 550. i i'd tell them to
go the other way
at the 550 to win 100 because it ain't
gonna happen
you're on that don't pass line you're on
the don't pass line of that one then
you've got it pretty much what what
about jameis what about him as an idea
what do you think about him well he's a
free agent so i i could obviously i
could see that you know i mean
they're not going to give up a lot of
capital bringing a big name quarterback
but if james you know and depending on
the deal and
everything else i mean maybe there's
some
incentives they could add to that but
jameis might also be
uh
other teams might be competing for him
too um but i could definitely see
someone like that
coming in ed bouchette thanks for the
time um i'd love to
i'd love to reconnect with you post uh
combine leading up to the draft to see
what's uh going on with the steelers
thanks for the call anytime appreciate
that that's ed bouchette read him in the
athletic i do you should as well
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here